The answer is M XOR M'.
The reason for this is because each cipher text
is the result of XORing a message with a key.
C is equal to M XOR K.
C' is equal to M' XOR K. Note that the K is the same in both cases.
If we XOR C and C', that's going to be M XOR K XOR M' XOR K.
The really useful thing that happens if you're trying to break this cipher
is these two Ks will cancel out.
That's why you end up with M XOR M'.
That doesn't tell right away what the message is.
If the messages were exactly the same M XOR M' would just be zero,
and this wouldn't tell us anything.
The ciphertext XORed will be zero, but they weren't exactly the same.
When the Allies XORed these ciphertexts they didn't get all zeros.
The reason for that was because of the abbreviations that were used in the transmission.
An example would be if the original message has Spruchnummber,
meaning serial number, maybe in the retransmission it became an abbreviation Spruchnr.
That would mean the place were the letters start to be different we start
to see differences between the ciphertext and the ciphertext prime.
Unlike the key which was pretty close to random,
there were a lot of things you could guess about the messages.
The Allies had a pretty good guess that the message was in German.
The Allies could start trying. Let's say they guess the message.
We'll guess it's M.
Then we could try seeing what we get when we do M XORed with a C XORed with a C'.
We can make some guess for the message.
Try XORing it the intercepted ciphertext.
That should give us back the other message,
and we'll look if that looks like a possible message.
This is definitely a painstaking process but something that can be done.
Once you get the two messages by this guessing process,
then it's easy to find the key.
Once you have the two messages through this guessing,
you had the ciphertext intercepted. Now you know the key.
Learning the messages might be useful.
By the time you've done all this work maybe it's too late for the message to be useful,
but learning the key could be really useful.
This was done by Col. John Tiltman who took these two intercepts
and determined the key that produced them.
They had enough content here that there were 4000 letters in the intercept,
so they had a 4000-long key.
This key was given to Bill Tutte. This was his first assignment at Bletchley Park.
He was to try to make sense of these key.
After about 6 months of work, he was able to determine
the machine structure that produced that key,
and this is what it is.
You have five lines going in.
This is the five bits in the Baudot code for encoding each character.
The rest of the machine is to produce the key bits.
There is an XOR with each of these wheels.
These wheels will rotate with each character.
Then there is another set of wheels that sometimes rotate and sometimes don't.
We have these two M wheels.
Based on the result of XORing the M wheels, either all the S wheels rotate one position
for that character or none of them do.
This was really the biggest weakness in Lorenz cipher--the S wheels all moved at once.